tourists are evacuating Yosemite
National Park this morning because of
dangerous conditions from a nearby
wildfire the Ferguson fire has burned
about thirty eight thousand acres in
California Sierra Nevada firefighters
battling the flames will work in nearly
100 degree temperatures today Dean
Reynolds is at the USMNT Valley Lodge as
visitors begin to leave Dean good
morning good morning well flames from
the Ferguson fire are getting closer to
where we are but a heavy layer of smoke
has been blanketing the park for much of
the last week and that's affected the
vacation plans of hundreds of thousands
of tourists and forced the closure of
Yosemite Valley for the first time in
nearly 30 years battling steep rugged
terrain and oppressive heat emergency
crews are racing to contain the Ferguson
fire for nearly two weeks flames have
chewed through more than 57 square miles
of forest in the Sierra Nevadas
blanketing nearby Yosemite National Park
in a thick cloud of smoke we're seeing
variable air quality but it's the
sustained exposure that concerns us
those concerns led Park officials to
close the seven and a half mile valley
causing the cancellation of at least a
thousand hotel and lodge reservations
during the peak summer season it just
got to the point the cumulative effect
poor air quality the weather forecast
saying were not looking at any relief
soon the decision gives firefighters
time to perform preventative measures
without interference from tourists many
of whom have had their trips cut short
we're gonna try to get out of here
before the big rush Nancy Devonport came
from Utah she says she's been here for a
week with 24 family members but the
dangerous air forced them to cancel most
of their plans it's not healthy to go on
hikes or any of the tours we couldn't
you know do a lot of the things we
wanted to do now popular sections of the
park will officially closed for the next
four days starting at noon local time
today but this Lodge where we're at
isn't taking any chances and wants all
its guests out
by nine o'clock this morning Gail all
right Dean thank you very much